ein Tag essen in Amerika wenn ich in den
Urlaub fahre dann muss ich zugeben denke
ich immer daran was gibt's da wohl zu
essen und das ist wirklich wahr wenn ich
so eine Reise plane dann ist das für
mich häufig das entscheidende was ich da
so cooles finden könnte und finden werde
und gerade bei Amerika würden
wahrscheinlich viele Leute sagen dass es
für sie vielleicht nicht so wert ist zu
bereisen für Essen aber ich sage so viel
wir haben in den 14 Tagen so viel gutes
Essen gegessen und auch im heutigen
Video deshalb freut euch darauf es wird
wirklich eine Reise es hat angefangen
mit einem leckeren coldbrookaffee nach
dem Tennis spielen wir haben tatsächlich
einmal Sport gemacht genau an dem Tag
vielleicht auch ein bisschen ums im
Video zeigen zu können und haben danach
Lust auf einen Kaffee gehabt sind unser
Nachhauseweg zu Fuß angetreten und an
einem kleinen Stand vorbei gelaufen der
cold brew im Angebot hatte
[Musik]
also wir laufen jetzt nach Hause vom
Tennis spielen dazu erstmal ein cold
Crew so kann der Tag starten ich habe
das richtig lieben gelernt hier in den
letzten Tagen in den Staaten weil es
gibt nirgendwo fast so richtig geilen
frischen ist immer geil deshalb zum wohl
meine lieben
wir haben gestern so drüber gequatscht
so ins San Diego könnten wir uns
eigentlich alle Mitreisenden am meisten
vorstellen zu wohnen hier in den Start
aber hier ist cool Essen ist natürlich
auch super falsch aus dass du so
oberkörperfrei bist hier schon so
Halloween Deko
ja das kennt man ja gar nicht mehr dass
du was ohne Sirup und irgendwas ist
normalerweise würde man da jetzt noch so
cream drauf machen mit irgendeinem
hazeln hat Geschmack zu Hause haben sehr
sehr geil und es wurde weiter belohnt
dass wir da einfach mal frei Schnauze
rumgelaufen sind und geguckt haben was
es so gibt denn wir haben einen wirklich
wunderbaren Laden gefunden der mir bis
heute nicht aus dem Kopf geht hungry
loose hieß er und das war so ein
italienisch amerikanisches Bistro
welches ist wirklich in sich hatte
aber im need for Sub wollte ich auch
schon immer mal essen ne also klar das
gibt's bei Subway aber ich meine so ein
real ich habe jetzt halt Sorgen dass wir
entlang des Weges noch was Besseres
finden aber ich glaube das sieht gut aus
oder so schön wie das ganze vielleicht
aussehen mag eine Sache war leider nicht
ganz so schön in San Diego und das war
unser Bett und ich weiß nicht ob ihr
mich verstehen könnt aber so ein
schlechtes Bett kann so ein Aufenthalt
und gerade in Urlaub auf jeden Fall
wirklich downgraden die Matratze war
viel zu weich man hat da drin voll
geschwitzt aber vielleicht bin ich auch
einfach nur verwöhnt von den Matratzen
von meinem Partner Emma der das heutige
Video auch unterstützt und das mit den
Matratzen im Urlaub stimmt wirklich und
dass ich zu Hause sehr gut schlafe auf
meiner Emma Matratze stimmt auch und
auch ihr könnt sehr gut zu Hause
schlafen auf den Emma Matratzen nämlich
mit dem Code Max Schlaf damit spart ihr
5% auf alles was ihr auf der Emma
Website findet ohne Partner wie immer
wäre es gar nicht möglich dass ich
solche Reisen unternehme und solche
Videos auch für euch mache deshalb
großes Dankeschön an Emma ihr erinnert
euch vielleicht ich habe Lara meiner
Freundin damals ein Emma Boxspringbett
geschenkt und jetzt habe ich mein
eigenes Bett gehabt mit ma 25
hybrid-matratze der Aufbau der Matratze
basiert auf orthopädischen Erkenntnissen
intensiver Recherche und aus erlesenen
Materialien zudem habe ich noch
wunderbar gemütliche Kissen zur
Verfügung gestellt bekommen Emma bietet
neben der Matratze auch Boxspringbetten
Lattenroste Topper und vieles weitere
sagen Love ist für mich persönlich super
wichtig weil ich funktioniere einfach
nicht wenn ich nicht acht Stunden gut
geschlafen habe und das ist kein Spaß
aber was macht Emma besonders und wie
könnt ihr davon profitieren die
Lieferung ist kostenlos ihr könnt dann
100 Tage lang Probeschlafen und die
ganze Zeit sagen nee ist doch nichts für
mich und ihr habt zehn Jahre Garantie
auf den Matratzen Kern die Bezüge sind
waschbar und somit auch immer wieder neu
und frisch wenn ihr das wollt und wie
gesagt habe ich etwas Besonderes für
euch nämlich den Code Max Schlaf mit dem
ihr 5% auf alles schwarz sogar auf
bereits rabattierte Produkte bis zum
28.11 gibt es auf alle Produkte bis zu
33 Prozent und mit meinem Code noch mal
5% on top der übrigens 6 Monate lang
gültig ist also klickt auf den ersten
Link in der Videobeschreibung holt euch
guten Schlaf nach Hause und weiterhin
viel Spaß mit dem Video ich vermisse es
schon ein bisschen
guckt euch das einfach mal an das war
ein Laden wie aus dem Bilderbuch die
Besitzer und Betreiber sahen wirklich
aus wie man sich die Arbeiter von einem
hungry loose vorstellt dann haben sie
das Brot im Hintergrund ganz frisch
gebacken für die Subs der Aufschnitt
wurde frisch geschnitten von
offensichtlichen Qualitätsprodukten und
man hat wirklich das Gefühl gehabt dass
man hier was gutes gefunden hat dann
haben wir es uns einpacken lassen mit
nach Hause genommen haben uns in unseren
Garten gesetzt und ich sage so viel es
hat sich gelohnt
ist aber Crypt
einiges erlebt hier auch schon in San
Diego aber erstmal müssen wir jetzt das
Frühstück erleben
boah sieht das super aus wir haben eine
Marinade in der Mitte ein mietbau außen
knuspriges Weißbrot cannoli natürlich
mit sahnefüllung
boah ist das knusprig noch geiler als
gedacht hätte
mit Ball meint ihr auch auf jeden Fall
ernst sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr
sehr sehr sehr sehr lecker könnt's mir
nicht leckerer vorstellen wenn ich so
dieses Italian meatball Ding hier
vorstelle dann ist das die Perfektion
also no joke ich weiß nicht ob es war
weil wir gerade Sport gemacht haben
unfassbar gut
[Musik]
boah auch das Crunch Level ne sehr sehr
gefährlich man sagt ja so Nelson Pots
Amerika ist einfach so viele Kulturen
und dann findet wenn man nur genug sucht
wahrscheinlich auch sowas in allen
bestmöglichen Ausprägungen deshalb bin
ich gespannt was wir heute noch so
finden wir werden auf jeden Fall suchen
nach so einem üppigen Frühstück müssen
wir uns erstmal wieder erholen haben
unsere Sachen gepackt und sind an den
Strand gegangen der nur 5 Minuten
entfernt ist deshalb schaut euch das
doch mal an
Wechsel mit dem Hamster so ein anderes
war
absolut beach
hinter mir sitzt ein verwundeter Krieger
wir waren nämlich gerade am Strand und
Eric wurde einfach von einem Stingray
ich rauchen drauf getreten habe ich
jetzt erfahren und zum Schutz stechen
sie wir haben halt so ein giftigen
Stachel deswegen tut das halt länger weh
als einfach nur jetzt wie zum Beispiel
ein Hypes oder so ja okay deshalb legt
Eric gerade seinen Fuß in Wasser ein
heißes Wasser heißes Wasser dadurch
denaturieren nämlich die Proteine im
Gift ne ganz wichtig das hält uns
natürlich trotzdem nicht davon ab gleich
zum Street farmers Marke zu gehen Eric
stärkt sich noch und dann geht es los
weil draußen ist gerade schon sehr
schöner Sonnenuntergang nachdem Eric
dann verpflegt war war es auch schon
wieder Zeit fürs Abendessen auch da
gibt's wieder was ganz Besonderes das
war nämlich ein Farmers Market sozusagen
ein kleiner Markt bei dem es Obst und
Gemüse vom Bauernhof gibt aber
gleichzeitig auch food Spots also so
verschiedene Stände sehr leckeres Essen
gemacht haben dann sind wir am Farmers
Market angekommen wir haben mitten auf
der Straße viele verschiedene sehr
belebte Stände gehabt es waren unfassbar
viele Menschen unterwegs haben gegessen
gelacht getrunken Spaß gehabt es war so
ein bisschen so wie das was man sich
vorstellt wenn man so an amerikanisches
street food denkt einfach so große
Vielfalt verrückte Menschen und alles
einfach sehr groß
wow hier sind wir jetzt angekommen und
wir waren am ersten Morgen hier weil wir
dachten dieser Farmers Market sei immer
aber es ist eine ganz ganz anderes
Szenerie die sich hier für uns bietet
glaube es gibt viel zu entdecken viel zu
essen wir machen uns einen kleinen
Überblick aber man kann so viel sagen es
ist schon echt richtig richtig hübsch
hier auch mit den ganzen Lichterketten
und so sehr
alter ich glaube wir suchen was zu essen
und probieren mal
[Musik]
wir sind bei Fat Boys Pizza und die
nehmen auf jeden Fall die large Slice
ist sehr sehr ernst muss ich auch was
sagen
oder das größer als mein Kopf von der
Oberfläche ist das locker eine ganze
Pizza und eine kleine normale Pizza
neuen Dollar finde ich sehr fein so wir
kommen aus Las Vegas und Ela das eh
alles krank teuer deshalb äh ich freue
mich sehr ist auch angenehm dass einfach
keiner um uns herum weiß worüber ich
rede
alles sagen gerade okay lass uns
probieren
boah man checkt das die Pizza in Amerika
ist sie ist jetzt nicht so napoletanisch
oder so aber sie ist schön dünn super
knusprig der Käse schmeckt sehr sehr
geil herzhaft
genau meine Pizza da sind die
rochenschmerzen schnell vergessen
[Musik]
wie Mexiko erinnert das ist super weich
geworden es ist ein bisschen anders als
das glaube ich sein müsste die sind
richtig richtig hart geworden so oder
davon dass sie gedämpft wurden okay hier
ist noch gar nichts drin okay die
Füllung kommt erst später
[Musik]
die beste Art und Weise ist zu
beschreiben ist maisknödel aber sehr
sehr lecker und diese grüne Salsa hat so
ein bisschen so eine Säure boah krass
viel geiler als gedacht auch so man
nimmt das so in Mund nicht so ja okay
aber ich bin jetzt bei der Füllung
angekommen
so pulled chicken gefüllt willst du
einmal testen wie spicy spicy für den
ist können wir vorstellen dass bei dir
nicht so spicy ist hier aber wenn du in
Mexiko selbst ist da erwartet dich viel
schlimmeres aber ich will nicht zu viel
gesagt haben
ist ein bisschen scharf aber ist nicht
so schlimm wir haben Glück Leute unsere
Mädels haben sich so ein Richie Sandwich
geholt und es sieht sehr sehr gut aus
ich habe hier noch ein bisschen
ergattern können mit richtig viel Käse
und Bacon make specialy just for you ihr
merkt es auf jeden Fall was los so die
die Straße lebt aber die Sandwich
bestimmt auch
[Musik]
erinnert mich auch direkt an der bessere
Version von dem Schinken Käse Toast auf
so einer Skihütte sowie der Vater von
dem Schinken käsefrost ist dazu gefällt
mir sehr gut hier ist auf jeden Fall
eine schöne Location für den letzten
Abend hier aber ein Spot war besonders
beliebt dieser Markt findet jeden
Mittwoch statt und so haben die Leute
ihre Favoriten und einer stand wirklich
vor allen anderen und zwar ist African
food man hat hinter dem Laden gesehen
wie jerk chicken in großen Pfannen auf
Gasbrennern gemacht wurde und einfach so
wirklich so richtig gekocht wurde mitten
auf der Straße bestimmt 50 m lange wir
haben es trotzdem angestellt ich meine
die Leute stehen bestimmt nicht ohne
Grund da erik hat sich eine Portion
bestellt ich konnte nur noch probieren
aber sowas habe ich auf jeden Fall noch
nie gegessen
[Musik]
ihr habt diesen Stand gesehen sagt du
willst du wie krank da war die längste
Schlange von allen und da hinten ich
glaube das waren East African stand
wurde so wild gekocht dieses chicken
dass sie ihr seht das wurde gerade
frisch gegrillt gebraten mariniert und
dann noch mariniert das ist jerk chicken
habe ich auch noch nie gegessen muss
gleich mal probieren
dazu habe ich einen Coconut Reis
en wow
Boss hat von allem etwas so sollte
Barbecue so sein
der kokosnussreis
[Musik]
war so süß und weich und alles mit Recht
ist dass der beliebtesten stand würde
ich sagen weil das ist einfach so
geschmacklich am krassesten ich finde es
geil dass die Leute sich das hier trauen
so weißt du so East African Food und das
ist der beliebteste stand das müssen wir
bzw Eric jetzt nur noch aufessen und
dann gehen wir einfach die Straße runter
bei unser Freund Nick aus der Schlange
eben hat uns verraten dass dort gleich
die Beachparty ist und die können uns
natürlich auch nicht entgehen lassen
aber kulinarisch und generell übelst
geiler Tag bis auf Erics brauchen steht
aber naja halbes oder so
[Musik]
ich muss wirklich sagen die Zeit in
Amerika auch wenn sie jetzt vorbei ist
hat mir so viel Freude bereitet wir
haben so viel gesehen so viel erlebt es
war so viel mehr als ein normaler Urlaub
wo man an einen Ort fährt um sich zu
entspannen wir waren ja in Los Angeles
Las Vegas San Diego wir haben im novo
gegessen dazu kommt noch ein eigenes
tiktok dass ihr euch zeigen möchte zwar
ein richtig schöner Urlaub und so konnte
ihr zumindest an der kulinarischen
Komponenten ein bisschen teilhaben
vielleicht konntet ihr euch ja auch ein
bisschen entspannen wir haben auf jeden
Fall jetzt neue Energie für die nächsten
Tage und Wochen hier richtig Gas zu
geben ihr seht schon ich stehe in der
Küche im Studio und auch hier gibt es
große Fortschritte freut Euch auf das
nächste Video bis dahin und ciao
hier ist ein für dich vorgeschlagenes
wehe hier kannst den Kanal abonnieren
kannst du gerne machen kannst doch bitte
machen mach nicht nicht sondern mach
danke tschüss